hello my name is Caleb Denby and welcome
back to game review of course game
review is the series where I analyze
games either historical past or present
and today I wanted to go over a game
between Fabiana Cara Juana and Timur
raja baath in this game Fabiano played
the move 1.d4 raja baath played Knight
f6 we have C 4 and raja baath lately he
has a big reputation as a huge Kings
Indian defense player but as of late he
has sort of been experimenting with the
more classical qgd systems as has
players like ding Lauren sort of the
Kings Indian defense was was dying out
for a second there you know even at karo
who used to play the Kings Indian a ton
has definitely switched the qgd but this
time Roger Bob getting back to his roots
plays the move g6 and it made for a
hugely exciting game there's why I
wanted to go over it the move Knight c3
came on the board for Bobby Bishop e7 e
for
d6 now and Bobby chooses a pretty
interesting line here I would call it a
bit of a sideline he goes for the move
h3 this is known as the mckagan oz based
or depending on who you ask for a time
there I was pretending I wanted to play
like this until I realized the Kings
Indian defense is just busted if you
play the best moves it's my hot take for
you here in this game black hassled and
then Bobby played a very very
interesting move in the move Knight G -
E - this is very much a non-standard
move in this position much much more
common is to move like Bishop g5 or
Bishop e3 just getting this Bishop
developed and my understanding of this
position was after move like Bishop g5
h3 is sort of aimed at making a move
f5 harder to achieve because white is
even actually considering - playing the
movement g4 in order to control this at
5 square and so because black or white
is sort of committed to playing against
this plan of a 5 + f5 black in general
should be quite happy
to switch to the more benoni style
positions with the move c5 and play
could continue with d5e 6 do you take on
on d5 and you do just get sort of a
benoni where this Bishop is looking a
little bit awkward on g5 and this pawn
is looking a little bit silly on h3 not
to say h3 isn't useful move in the
Benoni ever but it isn't perhaps the
most useful move and that white could
have been making in the game though
after night GE - perhaps raja baath
thought that the most c5 would be a
little bit less advisable here because
nate GE - very much is a move that you
can play against the Benoni and has a
very very clear idea the idea being
after some play you want to play the
move Knight g3 and eventually you want
to play the moves f4 and f5 and this
night is going to be very well placed to
support this plan the night on g3
supports the e4 pawn in the center
it supports the f5 Square as well and
most importantly isn't on f3 blocking
this pawn in on f2 and so this would be
a very very quick way for Fabia to get
active play of course you know he would
still want to play some more preparatory
moves like Bishop e2 and castling before
going for this type of crazy business
but he would be well suited to play
against the benoni in this particular
structure so because Bobby chose this
move with night GE - Roger Bobb sort of
switched game plans here after the move
Knight GE - this move of course also
doesn't apply pressure to the e5 square
so Roger Bravo sort of switched to
playing it more like a Pierce defense
rather than a King's Indian or a benoni
and he plays this strange-looking move
a6
to start with and this move does sort of
look like a waste of time at first
glance but the idea is simply to
continue with c6 and b5 and go for this
Queen side counter play sort of as
quickly as possible
Fabi continued with Knight g3 and
sticking to the plan c6 came on the
board by raja baath Bishop d3 Knight bd7
we have castles by white and now b5 and
raja baath is breaking through here on
the Queen side Bishop e3 by whites and
rajab of goes for the boat structure in
the bathtub structure depending on who
you ask
with c6 d 6e 5 + b5 and i think this is
actually not the most uncomfortable
position for black straight off this was
a pretty unique way of playing against
this sort of setup by Fabi going for
this c6 b5 stuff quite early on is not
something I'm really used to sitting in
the King's Indian but Roger Bobb
definitely knew what he was doing here
and I think he got a pretty reasonable
position out of the opening in response
to e5 Fabi plays this move d5 in the
particular position he's not really
suited to be taking on e5 as moves like
95 come with very very quick counter
play here and I don't think he's really
suited to just leaving this pawn on d4
either because of the issues on c4 this
Bishop is sort of also in the way of
this queen defending the d4 pawn so we
do see the move d5 C takes d5 was ROG
Bob's choice and now after C takes d5
Knight c5 hits this Bishop and this pawn
a very natural square for the knight and
the bishop comes back to c2 and now I
think raja baath does make a bit of a
mistake here the very natural follow-up
to this b5 plan for black is to play
this move b4 and then you claim you are
shaking loose some defense of this efore
pawn after move like Knight a 4 can even
expect the move Knight f d7 and black is
going to kind of fall back to these
plans of playing the move f5 in order to
break down this efore pawn even further
at a later date and I think in this
position black has enough activity with
this powerful Knight sitting on the c5
square the move f5 is definitely going
to be on the cards for black to try and
open up this bishop and I think black is
is doing okay here honestly I don't
think black has to too many issues in
the game though and we saw the move
Knight e8 by black and this is an
attempt to play the move f5 a little bit
quicker the obvious downside to this
though is by not playing b4 this
actually allows white to kind of make
his own clamps on the Queen side now
white is the one playing
before and all of a sudden this night
finds himself without a comfortable home
and it has to retreat back to t7 now
it's sort of stepping on this bishops
toes once again with this bishop now
being interfered with from the f5 square
and Bobby doesn't stop here he now
continues with the move a floor and it's
highlighting that this a6 b5 structure
is perhaps not as solid as black had
hoped it would be
we saw the move B takes a four by black
and Bobby takes back with the bishop
potentially also possible was capturing
back with the knight sort of challenging
these squares on the Queen side you
could see this bishop coming back to d3
at a later date something like Queen b3
rook c1 and just going to overwhelm
black on this Queen side Bishop takes
though is not a bad move either rook b8
comes on the board and now it's a little
bit awkward for table e to defend this
pawn so in fact he just offers up a
trade now though we do see sort of the
advantage to playing Knight a4 because
now this Black Knight can come back to
this active c5 square and it does and
the game we saw it takes on a6 Bishop
takes a 6
misterx attacked server key 1 and after
Knight takes a 4 rook takes a 4 Bishop
back to c8 and we ended up in this
position in the game and this is a
pretty interesting position to try to
analyze and try to evaluate White has
definitely gained a lot on the Queen
side with these active with his active
rook on a4 and his wide open files but
on the other hand and with the Queen
side totally blown up the play is now
totally going to revolve around the
Kings side so it becomes a question of
whether this rook coming to a7 is going
to be enough to generate active play on
the Kings side for white or if it's
actually going to be black with the
advantage here with these plans of f5
coming so quickly and in fact the
absence of the LightSquared bishop for
white I believe is is really going to be
felt here black still has this key
LightSquared bishop to attack with on
King side and white is sort of lacking
this Bishop to offer up any LightSquared
bishop trades to make his King safer or
to even just use it as a defender to
defend his King
and in the game it did turn out that it
was eventually going to be black with
the slightly more active play and this
leads you to suspect that maybe
something went wrong for Fabi
somewhere along these lines and I do
think it might have started with this
move Bishop takes a four I think if Fabi
could have preserved these two pawns on
the Queen side for example Knight takes
a four rook b8 just to move like Queen
d2 here we're still challenging these
squares we're not yet totally
simplifying things with b5 and if at a
later date Fabi does manage to actually
pick up the a6 pawn now all of a sudden
he has threats on the Queen side of the
board he doesn't have to divert all of
his play back over to the Kings side
because with just one pawn remaining on
the Queen side that's enough to generate
threats threats of queening in
particular to draw the black forces sort
of back away from this Queen side also
notably he is maintaining this
LightSquared Bishop which I can't stress
enough is actually a really useful
defender for white play might continue
it was something like Knight c7 notably
this Knight is still in the way so plans
f5 are still difficult to achieve this
turret can come to the Queen side and
it's quite clear and that the black
pieces are just a little bit awkward in
this specific case with the white
bishops sort of bearing down on this
Queen side the rook ready to invade I
think this honestly was very much a
better way to go for Fabi in the game
though we did see black get these small
advantages in our case Evan was played
in the game f5 immediately for black no
reason to hold off on this move he takes
a 5 g takes f5 and now Knight age 5 was
fabi's choice already generating some
threats on the Kings side as he now has
to with the lack of pawns on the Queen
side Bishop h8 was playing in the game
and now it turns out that the move
Bishop h6 was actually quite important
to play getting this Bishop actively
onto the Kings side before it gets shut
out by the move f4
unfortunately for Fabi he chose the move
Queen f3 here and the move f4 now is
going to be quite strong forcing this
Bishop back and now on d2 this Bishop is
just a little bit less happy than it
would be on h6 because just in a more
passive role as I've said before
thing really to do on this Queen side of
the boards play sort of resolves
revolves around these kings queens g5
now by raja baath is a pretty natural
move but it does however allow this
knight back to g3 where it can reroute
itself into the center taking advantage
of this pin queen g6 now steps out of
the pin so Knight g2e 4/9 g7 was raja
baath choice trying to come in to some
active squares rook e to a one by favi
is a perhaps a bit too optimistic
actually black has a very nice plan here
of playing the move Knight f5 and coming
into h4 for example if we sort of pass
net h4 is already going to be a winning
move in this case unfortunately for
black though this does allow the move
Queen g4 which would trade Queens for
white and then offer him very good
winning chances in the resulting endgame
so black comes up with a very very nice
move that move is h5 defending the g4
squared before playing Knight f5 now
after King h2 you see Knight f5 and
Fabia sort of forced to admit his
mistake of playing reggae 1 because now
he brings the right back to g1 and short
order
Queen d3 first actually Bishop g7 and
now Erick g1 anticipating the move
Knight age 4 at a later date
and now after rook g1 raja baath
actually switches plans here taking away
the age Foursquare from his Knight and
instead replacing it with this pot and
this is a really interesting idea
by raja baath with Knight h4 he would
very much be anticipating to move f3
coming on the board this is sort of his
plan to try and open things up
however with h4 he is sort of admitting
that he'd be okay with white closing
things off with the move f3 because he's
going to get such huge activity here on
the Kings side also notably he's always
going to be considering threats of
capturing this h3 pond with this
LightSquared bishop that still is an
annoying piece for white to deal with so
H for allowing blight to to close the
position if he likes but understandably
if Tommy didn't want to go for this
playing 92 instead to kind of cover some
of these key squares
Ruka p7 now and rook a8 keeping this
active rook on the board rook B to f7 is
transferring this rook to support this
f3 push and now Bishop b4 was fabi's
idea with 92 as well opening up this
square for the bishop unfortunately
though the play on the Kings side is
coming quite quickly in fact the move
Knight G 3 is already potentially
playable for raja baath with a nice
night sacrifice instead though Queen h6
at this point the players I believe are
very low on time already now rook C one
was fabi's choice hitting this bishop so
we saw Bishop d7 now in fact the move
rook a7 would be pretty desirable for
Fabi
keeping an eye on these rooks on the
Kings side but unfortunately tactically
this does lose to the move Bishop e5
when both Queen and rook are hanging so
we saw Brooke a6 instead going after the
d6 pawn now the only reasonable move
here for Roger Bobb is the move plate in
the game that move is f3 immediately
breaking things open on the Kings side
and now Fabi chooses an interesting line
where he actually starts with the move
Bishop d2 now I was watching the
broadcast live at this point and they
were all suggesting the move G takes f 3
the reason being we actually like this
Queen being on h6 for the moment so we
can capture on d6 with tempo giving
ourselves this nice deep on so that if
simplifications do happen we are going
to be quite happy in the resulting
endgame and I find myself agreeing with
their assessment because after a few
more moves
for example 94 roof takes d6
with tempo and the Queen now rook takes
f3 would actually be forced to keep the
game going if you just move this Queen
out of the way you're asking for Knight
takes d4 he takes d4 rook takes d7 and
it's all sort of collapsing for for
black here so or it takes f3 and play
might continue as such with white sort
of keeping some more pieces on the board
and honestly here black up the exchange
but with some problems with the King
with some problems with these Knights
coming in to take stuff
I'm not sure what would happen in a
practical game here the engine gives
zeroes but it definitely would be an
interesting imbalanced game however this
is not what Fabi goes for instead he
plays Bishop d2 first kicking this queen
from the h6 square Queen h5 now and now
G takes f 3 raja baath finds the only
move here that move not 94 which would
allow Knight takes d4 very good for
white but rather Knight g3 opening up
this rook and not allowing
simplifications due to this coming with
Czech opening the H file with checkmate
to follow so Fabi now finds the only
move for himself tonight g1 have to
defend this f3 pawn and raja baath goes
for the classic king's indian sacrifice
you just capture on f3 opening files
really wild stuff here Knight takes f3
it is obvious for white rat takes f3
this queen is attacked but Fabi inserts
this nice move rook a8 and this is
actually sort of saving the game for
Fabi here
Bishop f8 is the only move and the point
is we have no comfortable square to move
the screen to if we move this Queen
black is just going to capture here and
all of a sudden and this is hanging this
is hanging Bishop f5 is a good move sort
of defending everything and black is
just going to be winning in this
position but due to this move rook e8
check the good news for white is we
don't have to move this King this Queen
we have this counter punch of Knight f6
check in the position available to us
now in this position it turns out
there's actually only one way for Fabi
to maintain an advantage here and that
way is the simplest you simply capture
this night on g3 now understandably Fabi
didn't want to go for this because h6 g3
looks quite terrifying King g1 Queen
takes h3 is sort of a monstrous threat
of checkmate if you take on f3 well this
is simply going to be mate from Bishop
b5 check and there's no way to stop this
one Queen g1 checkmate but we do have a
better move and Queen takes f3 in form
of
and now for tech stuff eight we can take
on g3 King takes f8 we can take f3 with
check very notably so taking this night
turns out it works for Fabi
in time pressure though he misses this
idea and actually finds a very very
interesting idea
fans of Anatoly Karpov and chess fans
who remember in particular a certain
game from the 1987 World Championship
match will be quite fond of fabi's next
move unfortunately for Fabi though it is
only good for a draw with best play you
came up with a very exciting move Bishop
h6 here and this is a wild one putting
this Bishop on pre-floor on pries to the
attack from the Queen also would be
hitting the struck but of course in this
Queen is tied down to the fence of this
f3 rook so Queen takes h6 is just a
losing move the Queen takes f3 can't
even capture on c1 due to the f8 bishop
now though raja baath does find the only
move here it is the most natural move
you simply take on e4
now this threat is back alive this
thread is alive again
you cannot play Queen takes e4 due to
riff takes h3 and Queen takes h6 now
thread up Knight f6 has been removed and
this Bishop is simply hanging there's
only one line here that saves the game
for Fabi and that line is to deal with
this threat of new rook takes d3 by
playing the mover takes FA check now
ever takes f8 we can play rook g1 check
not capturing here and a lawyer it takes
f2 and bishop or queen takes h6 but rook
g1 check instead now King f7 this has
prevented and the threat of her takes f2
if you go the other way
we will also still just take this free
rook so King f7 we take on f8 now Knight
over to g5 we have to actually capture
this Knight to deal with these threats
and Queen takes g5 Queen f3 Queen f5 and
suddenly we have found the draw now
Bobby did actually miss this move it
takes f8 instead going for wrote g1
check if it turns out this is just going
to be a lose
for favi king h7 queen takes e4 check
but now Bishop f5 and this is a
devastating threat that cannot be
parried Bishop takes f8 was fabi's
choice giving up the Queen here but now
Rick takes h3 is check King g2 Bishop
takes e4 is check King takes h3 and
black actually does have a significant
enough attack to win the game here that
attack would actually follow from the
only move here Queen f3 check now if you
come to h2 you're asking for Queen takes
F to check King h3 Bishop f5 check rook
g4 clean g3 is mate so you do have to
come up the board to h4 now Queen takes
f2 rook g3 must be played Queen H to
check King g5 Queen takes g3 check takes
off this rook King f6 and now of course
with the extra material you can even be
so nonchalant as to play the move Bishop
takes d5 here and win but there is even
more forcing with check and then the
nice Bishop takes d5 I'm drawing the
King to this diagonal with Queen h1 to
take off the rook so very forcing line
there that raja baath understandably
missed with very little time on this
clock he went for bishop or queen f5
check instead and believe it or not this
actually throws away the win with rook
g4 miraculously being enough for a draw
here the issue is if you play a move
like Bishop f3 what happens well you get
checked on a7 King h8 you get checked on
g7 king h7 or King g8 rather is now
actually a lost position due to wreck of
a check picking up the Queen so you have
to come to h7 then the repetition is
apparent
so rather than go for this Roger Bobb
just gives Queen f3 check he takes up to
check and we repeat moves to end the
game and what a wild ride this game was
between Fabiana Cara Juana and team or
raja baath definitely a ton of back and
forth here by both players this is the
type of super exciting chess that you
have come to expect from raja baath he's
a very exciting player with openings
such as the kings in being giving us
gems of a game gems of games like these
unfortunately for raja baath this one
didn't go his way
despite his winning position didn't go
Fabiano's way either though with a draw
being found in the very very end very
fun stuff from this game thank you so
much for taking a look at it with me as
always my name is Caleb Denby and I will
see you in the next episode goodbye